Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur Ausgabe 87 bei Forschergeist.
Und heute geht es um die Zukunft.
Denn es sind vor ein paar Tagen die Nominierungen veröffentlicht worden für den deutschen Zukunftspreis 2021,
bei dem unter anderem auch der Stifterverband seine Finger mit im Spiel hat.
Und das ist ein Preis, der besondere technische Entwicklungen belohnt im Ingenieursbereich
oder auch im naturwissenschaftlichen Bereich.
Und wir wollen das zum Anlass nehmen, mit diesen nominierten Gruppen zu sprechen.
Und heute ist die erste Folge davon und dazu bin ich nach Forchheim gefahren zu Siemens,
zu den Siemens Healthineers und begrüße meinen Gesprächspartner für heute, nämlich Thomas Flohr.
Schönen guten Tag Herr Flohr.
Schönen guten Tag.
Ja Herr Flohr, wir sind hier bei Siemens, Siemens ist ja in vielen Bereichen unterwegs, das weiß man
und genauso auch in der Gesundheitstechnik.
Dieser Standort ist im Wesentlichen dafür prädestiniert, hier wird sehr viel gemacht, richtig?
Naja, an diesem Standort hier in Forchheim ist eigentlich ein Hauptzentrum der medizinischen Technik.
Hier sind verschiedene Geschäftsbereiche, wie wir das nennen, untergebracht, unter anderem die Computertomographie.
Genau, und um die soll es heute im Wesentlichen auch gehen.
Sie sind ja in diesem Bereich engagiert.
Und ja eine neue Entwicklung im Bereich der Computertomographie die hat dann auch zu dieser Nominierung für den Zukunftspreis geführt.
Bevor wir darüber sprechen, würde mich natürlich erst mal interessieren, wie Sie selbst zum Ingenieur geworden sind.
Was hat Sie denn in diesen Feld gezogen, waren Sie schon immer hier unterwegs oder ist das eher eine jüngere Entwicklung?
Naja, jetzt bin ich zunächst mal kein Ingenieur, sondern Physiker.
Das ist jetzt vielleicht ein kleines Detail, aber schon, glaube ich, wichtig.
Okay, wichtig.
Ich bin in diesem Gebiet eigentlich schon tätig, seit ich von der Universität abgegangen bin.
Ich habe mich mein ganzes Berufsleben lang mit der Computertomographie beschäftigt.
Ist vielleicht etwas ungewöhnlich, aber hat auch dazu geführt, dass ich, glaube ich, schon mit der Methode sehr verwurzelt bin.
Wie kam es denn dazu?
Es kam dazu ganz einfach, ich war promoviert an der Uni, war fertig, habe mir überlegt, bleibst du jetzt an der Uni, machst du eine Unikarriere
oder gehst du in die Industrie und habe mich dann letztendlich entschieden, nein du gehst in die Industrie.
Einfach aus dem Grund, weil ich im Grunde immer auch sehen wollte, dass aus den Sachen, an denen ich arbeite, irgendein Produkt entsteht, irgendwas nützliches.
Also ich war immer weniger an der hehren Grundlagenforschung interessiert, sondern daran, was wirklich anwendbares, praktisches zu machen.
Das ist ja immer so ein Konflikt, denke ich, in dem alle Wissenschaftler in irgendeiner Form stehen.
Ja.
ob man sich jetzt mehr der Lehre, der Forschung, der Grundlagenforschung widmet oder es in der Industrie macht.
Jetzt hätte ich gern gefragt, wie vergleichen Sie denn die beiden?
Aber Sie haben ja im Prinzip auch nur die eine Seite wirklich jetzt richtig durchlebt oder?
Naja, das ist an sich kein Widerspruch.
Ich habe die eine Seite durchlebt, auf Seiten der Industrie, bin aber nebenbei auch zum Beispiel an der Universität tätig,
an der Universität Tübingen, da konnte ich mich habilitieren im Bereich medizinische Technik.
Ich halte da auch durchaus mal Vorlesungen oder gebe Studentenkurse und das ist, finde ich, sehr bereichernd, auch diesen Aspekt zu sehen.
Also es heißt nicht, dass jemand, der in der Industrie arbeitet, dann für die Wissenschaft oder die Forschung verloren ist.
Das lässt sich durchaus vereinbaren.
Ja, kommen Sie auch dazu, Papers zu schreiben irgendwie auch wirklich?
Ja, natürlich ja.
Das ist auch ein wesentlicher Teil dessen, was wir in meiner/unserer Arbeitsgruppe tun.
Wir sind auch selber wissenschaftlich präsent, wir schreiben Papers, wir nehmen an Konferenzen teil.
Mit anderen Worten, eigentlich genau das gleiche, aber man hat mehr Impact was die tatsächliche Produktentwicklung betrifft,
weil das kann man ja eigentlich mit der Grundlagenforschung nur sehr indirekt beeinflussen.
Man hat in der Industrie sicher mehr Impact, was die tatsächliche Produktentwicklung betrifft, als an einer Universität, wo man so was,
wie Sie sagen, vermutlich eher indirekt beeinflussen kann.
Was muss ein Unternehmen so bereit halten, damit diese Integration von Wissenschaft auch wirklich so einen starken Forschungsschwerpunkt hat,
wo ja im Prinzip dasselbe Problem mitschwingt?
Man forscht zunächst einmal an etwas, von dem man eigentlich noch nicht weiß, ob man da in irgendeiner Form zum Ziel kommen wird.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch immer etwas, was so im Raum schwebt, gehen wir jetzt diesen Weg, gehen wir jetzt diesen Weg,
das kann aber sehr teuer sein.
Ja was glaubt ihr denn, wie erfolgreich ihr sein werdet?
Wissen wir nicht, kann fünf Jahre dauern, kann zwei Monate dauern.
Wie stellt sich ein Unternehmen an der Stelle auf, um so was zu ermöglichen?
Naja, man sollte die Freiheit haben, an solchen auch länger reichweitigen Themen konsequent arbeiten zu können.
Auch dann, wenn zum Beispiel allererste Erfolge ausbleiben, man aber von der Methode überzeugt ist, das weiter verfolgen zu können.
Und diese Freiheit die haben wir hier bei Siemens Healthineers gehabt oder haben sie immer noch.
Wir hatten auch den Support, also die Unterstützung vom Management, ein so lang reichweitiges Projekt, wie das photonenzählende CT,
wirklich über viele Jahre weiter zu verfolgen und über diese Unterstützung und diese Freiheit bin ich eigentlich dankbar.
Die Computertomographie ist ja heute ein extrem wichtiger Teil in der Medizintechnik, in der Diagnostik.
Ich glaube, jeder von uns ist schon irgendwann mal durch die Röhre geschoben worden zum einen oder anderen Moment.
Wenn man mal so ein bisschen auf die Entwicklung schaut und ich würde ganze gerne mal so ein bisschen gucken,
was sich jetzt eigentlich über die Zeit so getan hat.
Wir habe, glaube ich, nächstes Jahr Jubiläum für diese Technologie, 1972 wurde der erste Topograph zur Anwendung gebracht,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja.
Wo kommt diese Idee eigentlich her, welcher Bedarf sollte hier gedeckt werden und was war der erste Ansatz, der diese Geräte zum Leben erweckt hat?
Vor der Computertomographie gab es eigentlich keine Möglichkeit, wirklich in das Innere des menschlichen Körpers zu schauen.
Man hatte das klassische Röntgen.
Das klassische Röntgen macht aber letztendlich Überlagerungsbilder.
Das heißt, auf einem Röntgenbild sehen Sie die Überlagerung aller Strukturen längs des Röntgenstrahls.
Und da ist es klar, dass ja dichte Strukturen, wie zum Beispiel Knochen, alles dominieren.
Auf einem Röntgenbild des Schädels sieht man deshalb eigentlich nur die knöcherne Schädelkalotte,
man kann aber nicht in das Gehirn schauen.
Früher konnte man deshalb nur sehr mittelbar Aussagen machen über Veränderungen im Gehirn,
mit zum Teil für den Patienten sehr belastenden Untersuchungsverfahren.
Also invasive Methoden?
Invasive Methoden.
Die Computertomographie war die erste Methode, die es ermöglicht hat, überlagerungsfreie Bilder des Körperinneren zu erzeugen,
auf denen auch kleine Kontrastunterschiede, zum Beispiel der Unterschied zwischen dem Gehirn und einer Blutung
oder dem Gehirn und einem Tumor, deutlich sichtbar waren.
Das war der revolutionäre Schritt, den die Computertomographie gemacht hat im Jahr 72, als sie eingeführt wurde.
Was vielleicht nicht unbedingt allen sofort klar ist, ist, wie eigentlich ein Computertomograph funktioniert.
Das besondere ist ja, also auch hier kommt ja Röntgenstrahlung zum Einsatz und anders als jetzt bei einem normalen Röntgenbild,
wo man im Prinzip eine Quelle hat und dann geht das eben durch den Körper und auf der anderen Seite nimmt man das über eine entsprechende Platte,
die quasi belichtet wird durch diese Röntgenstrahlen, nimmt man das auf und schaut sich das dann an und sagt so,
ja okay, ist gebrochen oder ist nicht gebrochen, das war ja im Wesentlichen erst mal so, auch das war schon revolutionär,
weil man muss ja noch nicht mal in den Körper reinschauen, aber um eben sozusagen auch die Weichteile jetzt in irgendeiner Form erfassen zu können
und zu schauen was drin ist, muss man im Prinzip sich um den Körper herumdrehen und viele Bilder auf einmal aufnehmen.
Ja.
Das heißt, die Grundeigenschaft des Computertomographen ist zunächst einmal diese rotierende Strahlung?
Ja, ein Computertomograph ist letztendlich ein Röntgenstrahler und ein auf der anderen Seite des Patienten angeordneter Röntgendetektor,
der übernimmt die Rolle des klassischen Films, der zeichnet die Röntgenquanten oder die Röntgenstrahlen auf,
die den Patienten durchdrungen haben und wandelt sie in elektrische Signale um.
Diese Anordnung aus Röntgenstrahler und Detektor dreht sich um den Patienten
und nimmt während der Rotation etwa 1000 einzelne dünne Röntgenbilder des Patienten auf.
Und aus diesen Daten berechnet dann ein Computer das eigentliche CT-Bild, das die Weichteile des Patienten in einer Schicht abbildet.
Damit es so eine Schicht sein kann, muss ja dieser Detektor dann auch …
Also es ist dann eben nicht so eine breite Platte, wie man das bei einem normalen Röntgenbild hat.
Das ist nicht eine breite Platte, sondern aus dem Röntgenstrahl wird ein dünner Fächer ausgeblendet.
So eine typische Schicht in der Computertomographie ist ein bis fünf Millimeter dick.
Mit modernen Detektoren werden mehrere nebeneinanderliegende Schichten aufgenommen,
typischerweise zum Beispiel 64.
Damit es schneller geht?
Damit es schneller geht.
Und ist dann auch kein punktförmiger Detektor, also es geht jetzt nicht nur ein Strahl geradeaus,
sondern es ist im Prinzip so ein Fächer, wie ein größerer Winkel.
Das ist ein Fächer, man kann sich das vorstellen wie so ein Pixel-Array in der Digitalkamera.
Das hat in Fächerrichtung, also längs des Patientenquerschnitts, etwa 1000 Pixel
und senkrecht dazu, also in Patientenlängsrichtung etwa typischerweise 64 bis 300 Pixel.
Also mehrere Schichten gleichzeitig.
Mehrer Schichten gleichzeitig.
Und jede Schicht wird dann eben in diese 1000 Pixel aufgelöst.
Genau.
Wenn der Strahl dann kommt, der rotiert dann durch und dann gibt es 1000 Bilder pro Umdrehung.
In der Größenordnung.
Ja.
Nicht alle Geräte sind da gleich.
Nicht alle Geräte sind da gleich, aber das ist eine typische Größe, ja.
Und was ist dieser Detektor?
Was detektiert diesen Strahl?
Der Detektor besteht aus…
Also in der klassischen Computertomographie.
Der klassische Detektor besteht aus lauter einzelnen kleinen Detektorpixeln.
Ein solches Detektorpixel ist etwa ein mal ein Millimeter groß.
Und in einem klassischen Detektor besteht es aus einem Szintillator, das ist Gadoliniumoxid oder Gadoliniumoxysulfid.
Also ein Szintillator ist ein Element, was die Röntgenstrahlung in Licht umwandelt, richtig?
Ja, das wollte ich gerade eben sagen.
Es besteht aus einem Szintillator und einer Fotodiode an der Rückseite dieses Szintillators und die Detektion der Röntgenquanten verläuft in zwei Stufen.
Der Szintillator absorbiert das Röntgenlicht und wandelt seine Energie in sichtbares Licht um.
Der beginnt ganz simpel zu leuchten, in den meisten Fällen ist das schön gelb.
Also der beginnt wirklich schön gelb zu leuchten.
Und dieses Licht wird dann von der Fotodiode, die an der Rückseite angebracht ist, aufgenommen und in den elektrischen Strompuls verwandelt.
Das heißt, die Röntgenstrahlung wird vom Körper beim Durchleuchten des Körpers mehr oder weniger absorbiert.
Ja.
Entsprechend stärker oder schwächer ist das Röntgensignal, trifft auf diesen Szintillator
und das führt dann letzten Endes auch zu einem stärkeren oder schwächeren Lichtsignal, was man dann in den entsprechenden Strom umsetzt.
Im Prinzip ja.
Wobei ein Detail dabei wichtig ist.
Die Röntgenstrahlung, die aus dem Röntgenstrahler kommt, die hat ja nicht nur eine Energie,
sondern das ist ein breites Energieband von Röntgenstrahlen mit Energien von typischerweise 30 Kiloelektronenvolt bis etwa 120 Kiloelektronenvolt.
Das ist so die typische Beschleunigungsspannung einer Röntgenröhre.
Diese Photonen verschiedener Energie werden von den verschiedenen Geweben des Körpers auch verschieden geschwächt.
Nachdem die Röntgenstrahlen den Körper durchtreten haben, sind sie also nicht nur von ihrer Intensität her geschwächt,
sondern auch von ihrer Energieverteilung verändert.
Und diese Energieverteilung gibt an sich eine wichtige Information darüber, welche Gewebe da jetzt durchstrahlt worden sind.
Gerade diese Energieverteilung kann ein konventioneller Detektor aber nicht messen.
So ein bisschen wie mit der Atmosphäre, wo bestimmte Frequenzen, sichtbares Licht kommt durch, andere Strahlung wird absorbiert
und genauso ist es dann halt auch.
Also ein Detektor kann im Grunde jetzt übertragen auf ein Beispiel sichtbaren Lichts nur sagen, es ist hell oder dunkel,
aber nicht sagen, da ist grünes Licht oder rotes Licht oder eine Mischung aus gelb und blau.
Wenn man jetzt diese ganzen Daten einsammelt, das ist ja das, was dann die Computertomographie tut,
das heißt, man durchläuft den ganzen Körper in verschiedenen Schichten, je nachdem wie viele Schichten man gleichzeitig aufnehmen kann,
wie schnell das rotiert, wie schnell diese Daten auch eingesammelt werden können,
dauert es dann halt länger oder nicht, ich weiß nicht.
Der erste Computertomographie wie lange brauchte der, um so einen Körper einmal komplett so durchschnittlichen Erwachsenen abzutasten?
Naja, der allererste Computertomograph war ein reiner Schädelscanner, da konnte man nur den Kopf untersuchen.
Und um eine Schicht abzutasten brauchte der mehrere Minuten.
Der hat etwa acht Minuten lang sich langsam um den Schädel bewegen müssen, um genug Daten dafür aufzunehmen.
Heute ist es so, dass ein moderner Computertomograph 0,25 Sekunden braucht, um genug Daten für ein Bild aufzunehmen.
Der rotiert mit einer Rotationszeit von 0,25 Sekunden um den Patienten und nimmt dabei wie gesagt nicht nur eine Schicht auf,
sondern typischerweise 64 bis mehrere hundert.
Also da hat sich auf jeden Fall geschwindigkeitsmäßig was getan, aber die Limitierung war natürlich am Anfang,
erst mal der Computer muss diese Daten erst mal annehmen und speichern und weiterleiten können
Ja natürlich.
Das war natürlich eine Limitierung und auch die ganze Detektortechnik war relativ neu,
aber und das ist ja eigentlich warum überhaupt der Computer hier mit drinsteht, diese Daten als solche geben ja erst mal keine relevant Information so.
Ja, das ist anders als beim klassischen Röntgenbild.
Beim klassischen Röntgenbild schaut der Arzt das an, was auf dem Film oder dem Detektor abgebildet ist.
Beim Computertomographen sagen die eigentlichen Daten, diese tausend Röntgenaufnahmen aus verschiedenen Winkelrichtungen,
dem Arzt zunächst mal gar nichts.
Und aus diesem Rohdatensatz muss ein Computer erst mit einem mathematischen Bildberechnungsverfahren das eigentliche CT-Bild berechnen.
Und ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr in die Mathematik einsteigen, aber so wie funktioniert das grundsätzlich und wann wurde das sozusagen erdacht?
Das finde ich ein interessantes Beispiel dafür, wie eine an sich wertfreie Grundlagenforschung dann viele viele Jahre später eine praktische Anwendung finden kann.
Das Verfahren, um aus den Daten CT-Bilder zu berechnen, heißt Faltungsrückprojektionsverfahren.
Letztendlich misst man bei einer CT-Untersuchung die Linienintegrale der Schwächungskoeffizienten des Körpers längs des Röntgenstrahls.
Längs des Röntgenstrahls misst man also im Grunde genommen die aufsummierte Röntgenschwächung.
Und man kennt diese sogenannten Linienintegrale aus vielen verschiedenen Raumrichtungen,
der Computertomograph dreht sich ja um den Patienten.
Und aus diesen Linienintegralen berechnet man dann die Schwächungskoeffizienten, das ist das eigentliche CT-Bild, ortsaufgelöst.
Und eine mathematische Methode, wie man das machen kann, hat ein Mathematiker namens Johann Radon sich ausgedacht,
wie kann ich aus den bekannten Linienintegralen einer Funktion die Funktion selber ausrechnen,
und zwar soweit ich weiß schon im Jahr 1917.
Das war lange lange lange vor der Entwicklung der Computertomographie.
Aber seine Methode, der konnte damals von der Computertomographie nichts wissen, ist heute immer noch die Grundlage der CT-Bildrekonstruktion.
Ja im Prinzip ist es so ein Modell, man stellt sich einen großen sehr löchrigen Schweizer Käse vor,
man kann sozusagen an den verschiedensten Stellen irgendwie reinschauen und mal kommt mehr oder weniger Licht durch.
Und dadurch, dass man quasi denselben Punkt von verschiedenen Punkten aus mal betrachtet
und mal ist es so hell und mal ist es so hell, kann man daraus quasi wieder zurückberechnen wie …
Man kann es sich ganz simpel so vorstellen, das Beispiel mit dem Schweizer Käse ist gut.
Ich durchleuchte einen Schweizer Käse aus ganz verschiedenen Richtungen, und da, wo die Löcher im Käse sind,
kommt in irgendeiner Richtung ein bisschen mehr Licht an.
Das sagt zunächst mal gar nichts, aber wenn ich diese Abfolgen von mehr oder weniger Licht aus allen Raumrichtungen kenne,
kann ich dann durch dieses Rechenverfahren festlegen, wo das Loch im Käse war.
Bzw. wo alle Löcher im Käse sind und damit kennt man eben auch wirklich diese innere Struktur.
Und dann geht es eigentlich nur noch darum, das akkurat fein auflösend zu machen und die Unterschiede gut herausstellen zu können.
Ja.
Als die Computertomographie so das Licht der Welt erblickte, wie schnell hat sich die Medizin darauf eingeschossen?
Die hat sich relativ schnell darauf eingeschossen.
Es ist von Anfang an erkannt worden, was für einen wirklichen Fortschritt die Computertomographie in der Bildgebung bietet.
Und die Entwicklung der Computertomographie ist ja auch entsprechend schnell gegangen.
In den 70er Jahren hatte man reine Schädelscanner, in den 80er Jahren konnte man dann schon den gesamten Körper untersuchen,
allerdings immer noch in einzelnen Schichten.
Dann gab es eine revolutionäre Neuentwicklung, von der die CT auch bis heute lebt, das war die Einführung der Spiral-CT 1990 etwa.
Bisher hat man immer das Messsystem einmal um den Patienten sich bewegen lassen, anhalten lassen,
hat dann den Patienten zur nächsten Schicht transportiert, hat wieder das Messsystem mit dem Strahler sich einmal um den Patienten rotieren lassen.
Das ist langsam und fehlerbehaftet.
Was passiert denn, wenn der Patient sich dazwischen bewegt etc.?
Bei der Spiral-CT nimmt man einfach Daten kontinuierlich auf, das Gerät dreht sich immer, nimmt immer Daten auf
und der Tisch wird kontinuierlich durchgeschoben.
Damit konnte man das erste Mal wirklich größere Volumenbereiche, ganze Organe abbilden und nicht immer nur einzelne Schichten.
Dadurch ändert sich wahrscheinlich die Mathematik so ein bisschen, weil man …
Dann ändert sich die Mathematik so ein bisschen, das kann man aber in den Griff bekommen.
Der wesentliche Schritt war wirklich, jetzt konnte man das erste Mal ganze Organe sehen.
Dann ging das in den 90er Jahren so weiter, dann gab es einen weiteren wirklich wesentlichen Entwicklungsschritt, das war 98/99,
die Einführung der Mehrschicht-CT.
Bislang bestand ein Detektor nur aus einer einzigen Reihe von Pixeln.
Der konnte also wirklich nur eine einzige Schicht aufnehmen, ab 1998/99 war es dann möglich, mehrere nebeneinanderliegende Schichten aufzunehmen,
was die Untersuchungszeit zum Beispiel dramatisch verkürzt oder auch die Untersuchungslänge.
Wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen eine Kostenfrage gewesen oder?
Na das war nicht nur eine Kostenfrage, das war einmal eine Kostenfrage, aber auf der anderen Seite auch eine Frage der Mathematik,
weil die Strahlen, wenn man sich das mal überlegt, in Patientenlängsrichtung jetzt nicht mehr senkrecht auf den Patienten stehen, sondern schräg.
Wenn ein Strahl von einem Röntgenfokus, also einer Röntgenquelle ausgeht und auf einen ausgedehnten Detektor trifft,
dann steht der schräg auf dem Patienten.
Und das war in dieser ursprünglichen Bildrekonstruktionsmathematik so gar nicht vorgesehen.
Das ist ein Problem, das kriegt man in den Griff, aber es ist nicht so trivial wie es sich vielleicht anhört.
Okay, und dadurch ist dann wiedermal die Geschwindigkeit gesteigert worden.
Und die Geschwindigkeit ist ja nicht ganz unerheblich, weil es auf der einen Seite eine Belastung für den Patienten ist,
was jetzt den Gesamtvorgang betrifft, aber die Geschwindigkeit an sich spielt ja auch eine Rolle, um die …
Ich meine so ein Körper lebt ja im Idealfall.
Ja klar, zum Beispiel Sie möchten gerne die ganze Lunge des Patienten untersuchen.
Und bei dieser Untersuchung soll der Patient nach Möglichkeit den Atem anhalten, um einfach scharfe Bilder zu erzeugen.
Wenn der da jetzt munter weiter atmet, ja.
Dann verwischt das.
Wie lange kann ein kranker Mensch den Atem anhalten?
Wenn Sie das selber mal versuchen, Sie können das wahrscheinlich als gesunder Mensch problemlos 20-30 Sekunden lang tun,
aber ein Lungenkranker der hat mit fünf Sekunden Probleme.
Und in diesen fünf Sekunden muss die gesamte CT-Untersuchung der Lunge abgelaufen sein.
Und drum ist Geschwindigkeit so wichtig.
Ist das so der Stand der Dinge, wo wir bisher mit der konventionellen CT angekommen sind oder gab es noch weiter Entwicklungen?
Es gab dann weitere Entwicklungen, um andere Eigenschaften der CT zu verbessern.
Zum Beispiel gab es dann mal die Einführung der Dual Source CT im Jahr 2005.
Das kann man sich einfach so vorstellen, man baut nicht ein Messsystem, sondern zwei Messsysteme, in ein CT ein,
die messen beide gleichzeitig, dadurch verkürzt sich die Belichtungszeit für ein Bild auf die Hälfte.
Wozu ist das wichtig?
Dann, wenn man bewegte Organe wie das Herz abbilden will.
Und was man mal nicht eben anhalten kann.
Was man mal nicht eben anhalten kann, wo man im Grunde genommen 50-100 Millisekunden Zeit hat in der diastolischen Ruhephase,
um ein scharfes Bild zu erzeugen.
Und damit hat sich die, kann man glaube ich sagen, die Cardio-CT die Abbildung der Herzkranzgefäße mit der Computertomographie in der klinischen Praxis etabliert.
Also Dual Source heißt im Prinzip, dass man noch mal eine zweite Strahlungseinheit noch mit dazu nimmt.
Ja.
Jetzt könnte man ja sagen, okay um es noch schneller zu machen, nimmt man dann 10 oder 20, aber da ist dann irgendwann auch Schluss.
Naja, bei zwei ist eigentlich fast schon Schluss, einfach aus mechanischen Gründen.
Der Platz muss irgendwo da sein.
Okay. Das heißt, das ganze Modell hat sich zwar wunderbar weiterentwickelt in den letzten 50 Jahren,
aber in gewisser Hinsicht kam es an bestimmten auch so ein bisschen an seine Grenzen, kann man das so sehen?
Das kann man so sehen.
Man kann das so sehen, die Computertomographie hat im Grunde so eine Art Sättigungsphase erreicht.
Was die Computertomographie, die klassische Computertomographie sehr gut kann, ist, sie kann die Anatomie des Patienten abbilden,
kann sie deutlich abbilden, kann kleine Veränderungen in der Anatomie feststellen, zum Beispiel bei dem Beispiel der Herz-CT zu bleiben,
eine Verengung in den Herzkranzgefäßen, sie kann aber auch oft nicht sagen, was diese Veränderungen für den Patienten wirklich bedeuten.
Und ob und wie man sie behandeln sollte.
Das führt dann dazu, dass Folgeuntersuchungen nötig sind.
Bleiben wir bei dem Herzbeispiel, die Computertomographie kann sehr gut feststellen, dass eine Corona-Arterie eine Verengung, eine Stenose aufweist.
Sie kann aber nicht sagen, ist das jetzt relevant für die Durchblutung des Herzmuskels, schadet das den Patienten
oder beeinflusst das vielleicht die Durchblutung vielleicht gar nicht.
So dass dann in der Regel der Patient in den invasiven Herzkatheter kommt.
Und sich eine invasive Untersuchung anschließen muss.
Es gibt auch andere Beispiele, zum Beispiel kleine Veränderungen in der Leber, irgendwelche Leberläsionen,
die kann die Computertomographie sehr gut feststellen, aber oft nicht sagen, was ist das denn jetzt eigentlich?
Ist das gutartig, ist das bösartig, auch dann gibt es Folgeuntersuchungen.
Es gibt ja jetzt noch so eine verwandte Technologie, sage ich mal, zumindest von dem Grundansatz her, die Magnetresonanztomographie.
Wie verhält sich die Computertomographie zur Magnetresonanztomographie, wieviele Ähnlichkeiten, wieviele Unterschiede hat das?
Die Magnetresonanztomographie ist eine Methode, die ganz anderes Prinzip ausnutzt.
Die basiert also nicht auf Röntgenstrahlung und die Magnetresonanztomographie hat andere Anwendungen als die Computertomographie.
Die Magnetresonanztomographie kann besser als die Computertomographie zum Beispiel Weichteilkontraste darstellen,
aber viel weniger gut räumliche Auflösung.
Wann immer man scharfe Bilder braucht, wann immer man Darstellungen von knöchernem Gewebe braucht,
ist die Computertomographie sicherlich im Vorteil.
Die Computertomographie ist auch viel schneller und viel einfacher einsetzbar als die Magnetresonanztomographie.
Ein Computertomographie-Scan des ganzen Körpers dauert mit einem modernen CT-Gerät wenige Sekunden.
Eine Magnetresonanztomographie-Untersuchung dauert immer noch 20 Minuten, 45 Minuten, also vom Zeitaufwand auch sehr unterschiedlich.
Kommen wir mal zu Ihren jüngsten Entwicklungen.
Sie haben ja jetzt mit Ihrem Team hier die Computertomographie einen Schritt weitergebracht, das kann man, glaube ich, schon mal so sagen.
Wie sind Sie da rangegangen, was war das jetzt für eine Entwicklung und was sind die Neuerungen, die Sie hier auf den Weg gebracht haben?
Die wesentliche Neuerung in unserem neuen Computertomographen ist ein anderer Detektor.
Ein sogenannter quanten- oder photonenzählender Detektor.
Wir haben vorhin schon kurz über das Detektionsprinzip in der Computertomographie geredet, über die konventionellen Detektoren,
wie sie heute in allen medizinischen CTs verwendet werden, das sind eben diese Szintillator-Detektoren,
die in einem zweistufigen Detektionsprozess die Röntgenquanten erst in Licht und dann in elektrische pulse verwandeln
und die bestimmte Nachteile haben.
Weil die Tiefeninformation verloren geht.
Weil diese Energieinformation verloren geht, diese Detektoren können nichts sagen über die Energie der detektierten Röntgenstrahlen.
War die jetzt hoch, war die jetzt niedrig, das ist aber durchaus wesentlich für die Gewebecharakterisierung.
So ein bisschen als wenn man Farbfernsehen auf einem schwarz-weiß-Bildschirm anzeigt.
Ja.
Kann man das so sagen?
So als ob man ein Farbbild auf einem schwarz-weiß-Bildschirm darstellt, das ist ein guter Vergleich.
Die Detektoren können auch prinzipbedingt nicht viel kleiner gemacht werden als sie heute sind.
Heute hat so ein Pixel eine Seitenlänge von ein Millimeter mal ein Millimeter, das kann nicht sehr viel kleiner werden,
das heißt, die Bilder können auch nicht schärfer werden als sie heute sind.
Warum kann das nicht kleiner werden, was ist da die Limitierung?
Na die Limitierung ist die, ein solches Pixel wandelt ja das Röntgenlicht in sichtbares Licht um.
Jetzt muss man verhindern, dass dieses sichtbare Licht einfach ins nächste Pixel eindringt und dort ein Signal erzeugt.
Das nennt man Übersprechen.
Das heißt, die einzelnen Pixel müssen räumlich voneinander separiert werden mit einer Zwischenschicht, die optisch undurchlässig ist.
Und diese Zwischenschicht die muss eine bestimmte Breite haben, in der Regel 0,1 bis 0,2 Millimeter.
Alle Röntgenstrahlen, die auf diese Zwischenschicht treffen, sind aber verloren,
die tragen nicht zum Signal bei.
Das heißt, die haben den Patienten belastet, sie haben den Patienten ja durchdrungen, das war eine Strahlenbelastung für ihn,
sie tragen aber nicht zum Signal bei.
Wenn man jetzt die einzelnen Detektorpixel immer kleiner machen würde,
würde der relative Anteil dieser Zwischenschichten an der Fläche immer größer werden,
weil die Zwischenschichten eben nicht dünner als 0,1/0,2 Millimeter werden dürfen.
Oder wenn man sie kleiner machen würde, würde das Übersprechen zunehmen und dann wäre es unscharf.
Würde es zunehmen, dann wäre es unscharf.
Wenn man aber den relativen Anteil dieser Zwischenschichten immer weiter zunehmen lässt,
nimmt die Dosiseffizienz dieser Detektoren immer weiter ab.
Man hat immer mehr Röntgenstrahlen, die den Detektor treffen, aber eigentlich kein Signal erzeugen.
Und wie löst man das Problem?
Naja nicht mit konventionellen Detektoren.
Ja.
Deswegen …
Sondern hier musste was neues ran.
Hier musste wirklich was neues ran.
Und hier sind wir relativ früh auf photon-/quantenzählende Detektoren gekommen.
Solche Detektoren haben eine ganz andere Funktionsweise.
Die bestehen aus einem Halbleiter, in unserem Fall ist das Cadmiumtellurid.
An dem Halbleiter liegt eine hohe Spannung an, einige hundert Volt, so dass ein starkes elektrisches Feld besteht,
zwischen der Katode und pixelierten Anoden auf der Rückseite.
Und was hier passiert ist, die Röntgenquanten treffen auf den Halbleiter und werden dort absorbiert und direkt in Strompulse verwandelt.
Hier fehlt also der Zwischenschritt über das sichtbare Licht.
Die Röntgenstrahlen werden absorbiert, erzeugen im Halbleiter Elektronenlochpaare, die werden getrennt,
die Elektronen werden von den Anoden aufgesammelt und erzeugen direkt Strompulse.
Jetzt sind wir so tief in der Grundlagenphysik auch angekommen, Röntgenstrahlen.
Man stellt sich das ja normalerweise so als Welle vor, aber man weiß, alles, was irgendwie eine Welle ist, ist halt auch irgendwie ein…
Auch ein Teilchen.
Ist auch halt einfach ein Teilchen.
Das heißt, man kann sich diese Strahlenmenge, die den Körper durchschreitet, am Ende nach der Absorption durch den Körper,
treffen mehr oder weniger viele Quanten auf diesen Detektor auf.
Ja.
Und das ist wie so ein Dauerfeuer, was man sich vorstellen kann.
Wie so ein Dauerfeuer.
Man kann sich Röntgenstrahlen vorstellen als einen Strom von Teilchen, ganz simpel,
der Röntgenstrahler ist eine Gießkanne und aus dieser Gießkanne fallen Wassertropfen raus.
Und diese Wassertropfen sind die einzelnen Röntgenquanten.
Und dieses Cadmiumtellurid ist jetzt ein Kristall oder so was und in dem Moment, wo diese Röntgenteilchen auftreffen,
was macht dieser Stoff dann daraus?
Also der erzeugt unmittelbar Strom?
Na die Röntgenteilchen die treffen auf den Kristall auf, die haben eine Energie, wenn sie dort auftreffen
und diese Energie wird im Kristall abgegeben, das heißt, die im Kristall befindlichen Atome werden ionisiert,
es entstehen Elektronen, die da freigesetzt werden und diese Elektronen werden in dem starken elektrischen Feld,
das an dem Halbleiter angelegt ist, zur Anode hin abgelenkt und erzeugen da einen Strompuls.
Und umso mehr Partikel kommen, umso höher ist dieser Strompuls?
Jetzt ist es so, jedes einzelne Partikel erzeugt einen Strompuls für sich und je höher die Energie des einzelnen Röntgenquants war,
desto höher wird auch der Strompuls sein.
Jetzt haben wir das erste Mal eine Eigenschaft des Detektors, die ein konventioneller Detektor nicht hat,
die Höhe des Strompulses ist proportional zur Energie des Röntgenquants, das ihn erzeugt hat
und wir können nun die Höhe dieses Strompulses messen und haben deswegen auch ein Aussage über die Energie der Röntgenstrahlen,
die auf den Detektor aufgetroffen sind, die wir vorher nicht hatten.
Das heißt, niedrigere Energiestrahlen können als solche erkannt werden auch in ihrer Energiemenge
und die stärkeren können auch erkannt werden.
Ja.
Aber die kommen ja irgendwie mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig an oder?
Naja, es kommen viele Röntgenquanten gleichzeitig an.
Die erzeugen gleichzeitig Strompulse.
Ja.
Was man in den Detektor jetzt einbaut ist eine Zählvorrichtung, die alle Quanten zählt, die eine bestimmte Energieschwelle überschreiten.
Wenn man sich jetzt einen ganz simplen Detektor vorstellt, der nur eine einzige solche Zählvorrichtung hat
und eine untere Schwelle von zum Beispiel 20 keV, dann wird ein Zähler alle Photonen einfach zählen,
die diese Schwelle von 20 keV überschreiten.
Wenn jetzt da gleichzeitig welche ankommen, die eine Energie von 30, von 50, von 70 keV haben,
werden die alle gezählt werden, weil sie ja die Schwelle von 20 keV überschreiten.
Damit hat man noch nichts gewonnen.
Man kann aber jetzt in den Detektor mehrere solche Zählvorrichtungen einbauen mit verschiedenen Schwellen.
Das haben wir getan, in unserem Detektor sind vier Zählvorrichtungen mit vier unterschiedlichen Schwellen.
Machen wir jetzt mal das einfache Beispiel, ich habe gleichzeitig drei Röntgenquanten, zwei mit einer Energie von 30 keV,
eins mit einer Energie von 70 keV und ich führe zwei Schwellen ein, die eine hat einen untere Grenze von 20 keV,
die andere eine untere Grenze von 40 keV, dann wird die untere Zählvorrichtung mit der Schwelle von 20 keV alle drei Röntgenquanten zählen,
die beiden mit 30 keV und das mit 70 keV, die zweite Zählvorrichtung, die eine untere Energie von 40 keV,
also eine Schwelle von 40 keV hatte, wird aber nur das Röntgenquant mit 70 keV zählen, weil nur das überschreitet diese Schwelle,
die beiden anderen mit 30 keV liegen drunter.
Wir haben nicht zwei sondern vier solche Schwellen eingeführt
und können deswegen die auftreffenden und detektierten Röntgenstrahlen deshalb in vier Energietöpfe einordnen.
Um mal bei dem Bild mit dem Farbfernsehen zu bleiben, man würde halt sozusagen separat das rote, das blaue und das grüne Licht sich anschauen,
was ja unterschiedliche Frequenzbereiche hat und es funktioniert im Prinzip analog zu so einem Frequenzfilter,
kann man fast sagen.
Im Grunde ja.
Nur dass eben die Frequenz in dem Moment eben die Energie dieser Röntgenstrahlen ist.
Ja, wir haben im Grunde genommen einen Frequenzfilter mit vier Energiebändern.
So und das bedeutet, dass man jetzt mit diesen neuen Detektoren erstens also eine komplett neue Information enthält.
Ja.
Also man hat die Farbe quasi jetzt, die in dem Signal ist und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe,
ist halt auch jetzt diese optische Trennung auf einmal nicht mehr so erforderlich.
Genau, die optische Trennung, man hat einmal den Vorteil, dass man die Energie der Quanten kennt, also praktisch ihre Farbe.
Man hat aus dem schwarz-weiß-Bild ein Farbbild gemacht.
Dann gibt es diesen Zwischenschritt über das Licht nicht mehr, das heißt, ich muss auch keine optische Trennung zwischen Detektorelementen machen,
sondern die Detektorelemente werden im Wesentlichen selber durch das starke elektrische Feld definiert,
das heißt, ich kann die einzelnen Detektorpixel sehr sehr viel kleiner machen und erzeuge damit schärfere Bilder.
Wenn man vorher bei Millimeter als Grenze war, wo ist man dann jetzt?
Jetzt sind wir bei etwa 0,2 Millimeter für die Größe von einem einzelnen, 0,2 mal 0,2 Millimeter für das kleine Pixel unseres Detektors.
Im Vergleich zu 1 Millimeter mal 1 Millimeter.
Also im Prinzip die 25-fache Auflösung, wenn man sozusagen in jeder Achse ein Fünftel der Größe hat.
Ja, nur darf man es nicht multiplizieren.
Also theoretisch die fünffache.
Also fünffache.
Die fünffache Auflösung im Vergleich zu dem konventionellen Mode.
Ja okay, eindimensional.
Aber das ist schon eine Menge.
Es ist schon eine Menge, klinisch nutzbar davon wird sein, wir haben im Vergleich zu einem heutigen modernen CT schon die doppelte Auflösung,
das kann man sagen.
Doppelte Auflösung und das Ganze eben aber auch noch gepaart mit der Auflösung in der Strahlung.
Also dadurch, dass man diese vier Bänder hat, also komme ich schon dann auf 20.
Ja ja, wir haben die vier Bänder, wir haben die Farbinformation, wir haben eine verdoppelte räumliche Auflösung
und wir haben in unserem Gerät jetzt auch dieses Dual Source Prinzip angewandt.
Wir haben also nicht nur einen solchen neuen Detektor in das Gerät eingebaut, sondern gleich zwei.
Um auch den dritten Parameter, die zeitliche Auflösung, die Belichtungszeit pro Bild so kurz wie möglich zu halten,
um bewegte Organe wie zum Beispiel das Herz oder die Lunge gut abbilden zu können.
Ist denn die eigentliche Zählung der Quanten letztlich auch noch eine feinere Information
als man das vorher mit dieser Lichtstromumwandlung hatte oder ist das eigentlich vergleichbar in der Lösung
oder erfasst man die gemessene Energie auch noch genauer als man das vorher mit dem Szintillator getan hat?
Ein Szintillator hat in dem Zusammenhang noch einen weiteren Nachteil.
Ein Szintillator kann nichts über die Energie der detektierten Röntgenstrahlen sagen,
aber es ist bei einem Szintillator immer so, dass die Röntgenstrahlen mit der niedrigen Energie weniger Licht erzeugen
und deswegen weniger zum Signal beitragen als die Röntgenstrahlen mit der höheren Energie.
Ich kann nur die Summe messen, aber in der Summe ist es so, dass die, die die niedrige Energie hatten,
weniger beigetragen haben als die, die höhere Energie hatten.
Das ist für ein CT-Bild und die Kontraste im CT-Bild schlecht,
weil die Kontrastinformation im CT-Bild wird eigentlich von den Röntgenstrahlen mit der niedrigen Energie im Wesentlichen getragen.
Das heißt, ein konventioneller, klassischer Szintillationsdetektor liefert schlechtere Bildkontraste als sie sein müssten.
Das macht ein photonenzählender Detektor nicht, weil selbst in der einfachsten Betriebsweise,
wenn ich nur eine einzige Zählvorrichtung aktivere, also nur eine einzige Schwelle
und alle Röntgenquanten zähle, die diese Schwelle überwinden, dann tragen die alle gleichmäßig zum Signal bei,
weil sie halt alle gezählt werden und das Röntgenquant mit 30 keV wird genauso gezählt wie das Röntgenquant mit 70 keV.
Das heißt, die Röntgenquanten mit der niedrigen Energie tragen mehr zum Signal bei als mit einem konventionellen Szintillationsdetektor,
das heißt, die Bildkontraste sind besser, die sind prinzipbedingt mit einem photonenzählenden Detektor höher als mit einem Szintillationsdetektor.
Und man kann dann vor allem, weil man die Daten unterscheiden kann, sehr viel feiner das auch nachtunen und sagen…
Man kann es dann auch noch zusätzlich sehr viel feiner nachtunen.
Man kann diese Aufteilung in die vier Farbtöpfe nehmen, um Gewebe viel feiner zu charakterisieren,
um viel besser sagen zu können, was sehe ich da eigentlich, auch um verschiedene Materialien voneinander unterscheiden zu können.
Ein Problem in der CT-Bildgebung ist ja, dass die CT nur auf die Röntgenschwächung reagiert.
Materialien, die chemisch unterschiedlich sind, aber die gleiche Röntgenschwächung aufweisen,
erscheinen im CT-Bild gleichartig.
Ein einfaches Beispiel dafür ist, bei den meisten CT-Untersuchungen wird iodhaltiges Kontrastmittel verabreicht.
Iod hat eine relativ hohe Röntgenschwächung.
Iod reichert sich in den Gefäßen an.
Diese iodgefüllten Gefäße schwächen dann die Röntgenstrahlung stärker und erscheinen auf dem CT-Bild hell.
Hell für mehr geschwächt.
Hell für mehr geschwächt, stärker geschwächte Objekte werden auf einem CT-Bild heller dargestellt.
Die Knochen schwächen die Röntgenstrahlung auch stark.
Das heißt, auch Knochen sind auf einem CT-Bild hell, sie sind weiß.
Man kann jetzt oft ohne anatomische Erkenntnisse allein aufgrund der Helligkeit im CT-Bild nicht unterscheiden,
ist das jetzt ein Kontrastmitteliodgefülltes Gefäß oder ist das ein Knochen.
Das hat wiederum eine besondere Rolle, wenn man die Herzkranzgefäße des Patienten abbildet.
Um die Herzkranzgefäße abbilden zu können, hat man dem Patienten ein iodhaltiges Kontrastmittel gegeben,
damit dieses Iod in den Herzkranzgefäßes sie im CT-Bild hell macht.
Viele Menschen haben aber auch Verkalkungen in den Herzkranzgefäßen.
Diese Verkalkungen sind auch hell und man kann dann auf einem normalen CT-Bild oft nicht unterscheiden,
ja ist das jetzt eine Verkalkung oder ist das das kontrastmittelgefüllte Gefäßlumen.
Man kann bei Patienten, die Verkalkungen haben in den Herzkranzgefäßen, oft nicht sagen,
ja ist denn das Gefäß an dieser Stelle eigentlich noch durchlässig?
Solche Patienten müssen dann zum Beispiel gleich in einem Herzkatheter untersucht werden.
Mit dem neuen CT kann ich, weil ich ja die Energieinformationen in vier Energietöpfen kenne,
das Calcium, die Verkalkung trennen von dem Iod, weil die das Spektrum der Röntgenstrahlen anders beeinflussen,
also sprich, letztendlich das Signal in anderen Energiebereichen…
Die haben eine andere Signatur.
Ich kann also das Calcium von dem iodgefüllten Gefäß trennen und kann das Calcium markieren und aus dem Bild entfernen,
so dass der Blick auf das unverstellte Gefäßlumen bleibt und man wirklich auch bei Kalzifizierungen sagen kann,
ja hier ist das Gefäß eigentlich noch durchlässig oder nicht.
Das heißt, um das mal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen,
durch diesen neuen Detektor mit diesem Cadmiumtellurid, der unmittelbaren Umwandlung der Röntgenstrahlen in eine Strominformation,
die höher auflöst und die eben auch diese unterschiedlichen Energielevel zumindest in diesen vier Abstufungen noch unterscheidet,
erreicht man auf der einen Seite eine sehr viel höhere Bildauflösung, also fünfmal so viele Pixel auf demselben Raum,
das heißt, man kann es feiner unterscheiden.
Man hat höhere Kontraste dadurch, dass man sehr viel besser die Information als solche messen kann
und eben auch diese Signaturen unterschiedlicher Stoffe voneinander trennen kann
und nicht nur so ein, da ist was oder da ist was nicht Information bekommt.
Und das allein ist ja schon ein nennenswerter Fortschritt, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja.
Also das ist ja eine sehr erstrebenswerte Eigenschaft.
Ja, das denken wir auch.
Ja.
Sie haben das sehr gut zusammengefasst, wir können sehr viel schärfere Bilder erzeugen,
wir können Bilder mit höherem Bildkontrast erzeugen und wir können durch die Signatur,
durch die Frequenzsignatur Stoffe chemisch voneinander unterscheiden,
die auf einem konventionellen CT-Bild gleich aussehen.
Und wir können auch sehr gut bewegte Organe damit abbilden wegen dem Dual-Source-Prinzip
und können damit auch zum Beispiel Herz oder Lunge deutlich besser charakterisieren als vorher.
Aber Dual Source gab es ja auch schon vorher.
Dual Source gab es auch vorher.
Gab es da trotzdem noch eine Geschwindigkeitssteigerung?
Nein, das gab es auch vorher, aber wir können jetzt sozusagen diese zusätzlichen Verbesserungen auch mit der Geschwindigkeit eines Dual Source kombinieren.
Die höhere Geschwindigkeit kann man auch noch bei einer höheren Bewegung,
entweder der Organe oder des Körpers als solchem, immer noch scharfe Bilder machen.
Genau.
Das ist halt wie ein Foto schießen während jemand läuft.
Ist wie Fotoschießen, ist wie Sportfotografie.
Wenn jemand schnell läuft, dann möchte man eine kurze Belichtungszeit haben,
man möchte aber auch eine Kamera haben, die sehr viele feine Pixel hat, damit das Bild scharf ist,
und das ist auch schön, wenn man den in Farbe abbilden kann.
Benötigen denn diese Detektoren mehr Strahlung als die alten??
Nein. Nein, die benötigen im Gegenteil sogar weniger Strahlung, dadurch dass sie feiner geteilt sind,
dass das Messsystem besser ist und dadurch dass sie Kontraste besser abbilden als konventionelle Detektoren,
kommt man mit weniger Röntgenstrahlung für den Patienten aus.
Und erste klinische Untersuchungen von klinischen Partnern von uns haben schon gezeigt,
dass das 40 Prozent sein kann, also durchaus beträchtlich.
Mhm /bejahend/
Man kommt mit etwa 40 Prozent weniger Strahlendosis aus.
Wieviel weniger Strahlung ist das dann im Vergleich zu dem ersten Computertomographen?
Wie weit sind wir davon entfernt jetzt?
Ach je, ich glaube, das kann man so gar nicht vergleichen.
Das sind aber sicher Größenordnungen.
Also um das mal einzuordnen, ein modernes CT-Gerät braucht für eine Untersuchung etwa eine Strahlendosis von
je nachdem was man untersucht, würde man sagen, 0,5 bis 4-5 Millisievert.
Und die jährliche Hintergrundbelastung, die einfach dadurch entsteht, dass es Strahlenquellen überall in der Natur gibt,
die beträgt etwa 3 Millisievert.
Also wir sind in der Größenordnung von der jährlichen Hintergrundbelastung für einen CT-Scan oder auch schon deutlich darunter.
Also Bananen sind genauso gefährlich sozusagen.
Bananen weiß ich nicht, aber zum Beispiel …
Den wird ja immer hohe Strahlen, Radioaktivität nachgesagt.
Ja, ständig über den Atlantik zu fliegen, ist sicherlich genauso gefährlich.
Ja, okay.
Jetzt sind die ganzen Fortschritte technischer Natur natürlich interessant, aber es gibt ja auch noch andere Entwicklungen,
insbesondere im Computerbereich und in bildgebenden Verfahren.
In den letzten Jahren hat sich ja eine ganze Menge getan, weil die Computer natürlich schneller geworden sind,
Speicherung von großen Datenmengen ist in zunehmenden Maße einfacher und günstiger geworden.
Und überhaupt sieht man ja auch, dass so bildgebende Verfahren,
mathematische Methoden aus irgendwie komplexen Bildmaterial etwas neues und anschaulicheres zu erzeugen,
ja, das greift irgendwie um sich.
Sagen wir mal, die Ablichtung von Umgebung aus Luftbildern, wo man dann irgendwie Bildern aus verschiedenen Bereichen schießt,
um daraus so ein 3D-Modell zu machen, ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein bisschen vergleichbar mit dem,
was Sie in dem Computertomographen machen, weil das ja eigentlich auch mehr oder weniger Luftbilder aus verschiedenen Winkeln sind.
Wie hat sich dieser Softwareteil weiterentwickelt und spielt das jetzt hier in der nächsten Generation von Tomographen auch eine Rolle?
Naja, für diesen Softwareteil gibt es eigentlich zwei Aspekte.
Der eine Aspekt ist einer, den man vielleicht gar nicht so sehr auf Anhieb sieht.
Aber solche lernbasierten Verfahren oder künstliche Intelligenz wird in einem Computertomographen heute schon verwendet,
um dem Benutzer die Bedienung zu vereinfachen.
Wenn zum Beispiel ein Computertomographie-Scan gemacht wird, wird zunächst eine Übersichtsaufnahme gemacht.
Da wird, das entspricht etwa einem konventionellen Röntgenbild.
Dabei wird der Detektor und die Röhre nicht gedreht, sondern die stehen still,
fahren einmal über den Patienten drüber und erzeugen eine röntgenbildähnliche Darstellung,
auf der der Arzt oder die MTA dann die eigentliche Untersuchung plant.
Sie will die Lunge untersuchen und muss daher den Untersuchungsbereich so festlegen, dass die Lunge genau getroffen wird.
Erst mal allein zur Positionierung und zur Kalibrierung?
Allein für Positionierung, das machen heute Computeralgorithmen, die schlagen ihr das automatisch vor,
schau mal her, ich habe die Lunge erkannt, du solltest deinen Scanbereich von hier bis da definieren
und ich habe auch erkannt, dass der Patient nicht auf der optimalen Höhe liegt,
sondern dass du den ein bisschen höher legen solltest.
Dahinter steckt auch schon künstliche Intelligenz, lernbasierte Verfahren.
Also Machine-Learning-Verfahren.
Einfach Machine-Learning, die einfach an vielen vielen Patientenbildern gelernt haben, wie die Lunge aussieht
Und wie man letztendlich vorschlagen kann, das ist der richtige Scanbereich.
Das ist sehr sehr unspektakulär, wird aber heute schon in vielen CTs von Ärzten ganz selbstverständlich genutzt.
Dann gibt es den anderen Bereich, den Sie hier ansprechen, was mache ich denn mit den eigentlichen Bildern, die ich erzeugt habe?
Kann ich da mit künstlicher Intelligenz mehr Information oder andere Informationen herausholen als der Radiologe?
Auch da gibt es Techniken, die auch heute schon im Einsatz sind.
Jetzt nicht, um den Radiologen zu ersetzen, wie oft die Angst ist, sondern einfach um ihn zu unterstützen und ihnen Routineaufnahmen abzunehmen.
In CT-Bildern bestimmte Organe automatisch zu finden, automatisch darin bestimmte Messungen vorzunehmen,
zum Beispiel den Durchmesser der Aorta oder bei Herzaufnahmen automatisch festzustellen,
wieviel Kalk ist denn jetzt in den Herzkranzgefäßen?
Das wird heute schon getan und so was ist in der Regel basierend auf Maschinenlernen.
Also das ist die erste unmittelbare Anwendung des Maschinenlernens, Bilder besser darzustellen,
automatische Messungen vorzunehmen, um den Radiologen zu entlasten.
Dann der nächste Schritt kann sein, jetzt kann ich automatisch Anomalien in den Bildern entdecken, auch daran arbeiten wir.
Beispiel dafür ist, bei einem Schädelscan möchte man automatisch eine Blutung im Schädel entdecken können,
das kann ein Computer, um den befundenen Arzt darauf hinzuweisen, schau mal, da ist ein Fall.
In deiner ganzen Liste von Fällen da ist einer, der hat vermutlich eine Blutung, schau den mal als ersten an.
Und wenn wir jetzt weitergehen, gerade mit diesem neuen CT haben wir ja eine Vielzahl von neuen Informationen,
auch von anderen Informationen.
Und diese Informationen dann zu verbinden mit maschinenlernenden Ansätzen, um noch mehr aus diesen Informationen rauszuholen,
um Krankheitsprozesse vielleicht wirklich früher erkennen zu können oder früher auch charakterisieren zu können,
ist sicher ein wesentlicher Schritt.
Machine-Learning, also maschinelles Lernen erfordert ja sozusagen auch immer eine Wahrheit zu haben.
Man kann ja so einen Algorithmus nur dann irgendwas erkennen lassen, wenn auch klar ist so,
okay guck dir das mal an, das war, was weiß ich, ein Tumor, hier war eine Verkalkung, hier Blutung etc. tausend Beispiele
und so funktioniert ja das Maschinenlernen, indem man eben einfach möglichst viele Wahrheiten und viele Unwahrheiten präsentiert
und immer sagt, das war es und das war es nicht.
Ich erinnere mich selber noch, Bekannte von mir war Radiologin und hat auch sehr viel so Tumoruntersuchung,
Frühuntersuchung gemacht und so weiter, und das war halt irre.
Also erst mal welche Technik in der Frühzeit so erforderlich war, also hochgradig kalibrierte schwarzweiß-Bildschirme,
die so diese ganzen Graustufen auf eine extrem präzise Art und Weise angezeigt haben.
Und trotzdem schaute man im Wesentlichen auf so einen waberndes Nichts, wo es einfach extrem viel Erfahrung braucht,
um diese Bilder überhaupt in irgendeiner nennenswerten Form interpretieren zu können.
Ich denke, jeder kennt das auch, wenn man selbst mal in Behandlung war und dann kriegt man so ein Röntgenbild gezeigt,
und das ist einfach im Wesentlichen alles so Nebel morgens um 7 Uhr und dann zeigen die Ärzte drauf und sagen,
hier sehen Sie ja, hier da ist irgendwie alles im Eimer und da ist alles super.
Und ich so, ja okay, meinetwegen.
Sprich, es braucht viel Erfahrung.
Die Frage ist, wie arbeiten Sie jetzt mit den Radiologinnen und Radiologen zusammen,
inwiefern ist jetzt auch Siemens hier als im Wesentlichen ja geräteherstellender Produzent, Technologieproduzent
mit der Forschungslandschaft und mit den Ärztinnen und Ärzten verbunden,
dass man diese Information auch zuverlässig einsammeln und eben auch erlernen kann?
Wir haben ein enges Netz von klinischen Partnern, mit denen wir seit zum Teil vielen Jahren in Kooperation zusammenarbeiten.
Mit denen wir dann auch zum Beispiel neue Geräte, wie jetzt diesen Computertomographen, erproben
und deren Feedback dann bei uns natürlich sehr wesentlich einfließt.
Das ist für uns auch ganz ganz wesentlich, ohne dieses enge Netz klinischer Partner hätten wir zum Beispiel den,
also den quantenzählenden Computertomographen vermutlich nicht so schnell in der Form,
wie wir ihn jetzt haben, marktreif gebracht.
Also das ist so, wir haben zum Teil langjährige Kooperationspartner, mit denen wir zusammen Studien durchführen,
mit denen wir zusammen neue Software evaluieren und die uns wirklich wertvolles Feedback geben.
Also mit anderen Worten, Sie sind da in einem permanenten Austausch mit Universitätskliniken und anderen Forschungsstandorten.
Ja, sind wir.
Um diese Information dann auch entsprechend prüfen zu können.
Wenn ich es richtig sehe, das ist auch noch so ein bisschen auf einer zweiten Ebene,
also es wird jetzt, glaube ich, auch gerade ein neues Produktionszentrum errichtet in Forchheim für diese neue Technologie?
Es ist ein Produktionszentrum errichtet worden für die Kristallzucht hier in Forchheim.
Der Cadmiumtellurid-Kristall ist ja der wesentliche Bestandteil dieses Detektors.
Und wir haben hier ein Zentrum gebaut, in dem wir diesen Kristall einerseits in der nötigen hohen Qualität produzieren können,
aber dann auch in der Menge, die wir für eine breite Einführung dieser CT-Geräte brauchen.
Das existiert schon oder das entsteht gerade?
Das existiert, also dieses Kristallzentrum existiert, das ist eingeweiht worden, die haben auch schon Kristalle.
Funktioniert auch schon.
Das ist so auch ein wesentlicher Schritt, wir wollen ja jetzt nicht ein solches CT irgendwo installieren
und manufakturartig einen solchen Detektor mal zusammenbasteln.
Sondern ein solcher Detektor der muss sich ja industriell fertigen lassen, weil wir idealerweise viele hunderte solche CT produzieren wollen.
Und der muss sich auch industriell zu akzeptablen Kosten fertigen lassen und natürlich mit der geforderten Qualität.
Das ist ein mindestens ebenso wesentlicher Schritt, das zu erreichen.
Wenn man jetzt auf die neue Technik schaut, so in der Summe, welche Möglichkeiten das Ganze ergibt,
wie schätzen Sie die Auswirkung, die potenziellen Auswirkungen, sage ich mal, auf medizinische Diagnostik aus?
Was könnte durch diesen Sprung, diesen technischen Schritt ermöglicht werden,
wo derzeit vielleicht die Diagnostik im Grenzbereich des ungefähren arbeitet?
Ja wir glauben, dass wir mit diesem Computertomographen einen wesentlichen Schritt in die Richtung gehen,
CT-Bilder aussagekräftiger zu machen.
Ich habe bereits gesagt, CT-Bilder können kleine Veränderungen auch heute schon empfindlich darstellen,
aber sie können oft nicht sagen, was bedeutet das für den Patienten?
Und hier wollen wir einen Schritt weitergehen und wollen eine möglichst umfassende Aussage ermöglichen,
um so zum Beispiel frühere Diagnosen oder auch bessere Diagnosen mit weniger Folgeuntersuchungen zu ermöglichen.
Um bei diesem Herzbeispiel zu bleiben, Patienten, die starke Verkalkungen in den Herzkranzgefäßen haben,
haben manchmal gar kein wirkliches Problem.
Diese Verkalkungen blockieren den Blutfluss in den Herzkranzgefäßen nicht.
Trotzdem müssen die sich heute einer invasiven Herzkatheteruntersuchung unterziehen,
wenn man die Durchblutung der Herzkranzgefäße wirklich feststellen will,
weil man auf einem herkömmlichen CT das nicht kann, weil diese Kalzifizierungen nicht vom Iod in den Gefäßen zu trennen sind
und alles überstrahlen, so dass man im Grunde nichts sieht.
Wir hoffen, dass wir auch für diese Patienten in Zukunft sicher sagen können, diese Koronararterie,
dieses Herzkranzgefäß ist trotz dem ganzen Kalk ausreichend durchblutet, und so zum Beispiel diesen Patienten den Gang zum Herzkatheter ersparen.
Auch hoffen wir, dass wir zum Beispiel gerade in der Onkologie kleine Tumoren in der Leber deutlich früher erkennen können,
durch die besseren Bildkontraste, deutlich besser charakterisieren können und sie vor allem auch standardisierter darstellen zu können
als mit einem jetzigen CT.
Wir glauben schon, dass wir da einen wesentlichen Schritt gemacht haben.
Und wenn ich das sagen darf, werden wir darin auch von anderen bestätigt, von klinischen Partnern,
zum Beispiel der Professor Krestin, der ist einer der frühen Nutzer dieses Systems, der ist Radiologiechef in Rotterdam
in den Niederlanden, der hat wirklich gesagt, er glaubt, dass in naher Zukunft jedes CT ein quantenzählendes Ct sein wird.
Und vielleicht auch noch ein Ereignis, das schon bemerkenswert ist, das Gerät hat jetzt seine USA-Zulassung bekommen,
in den USA macht diese Zulassung eine Behörde, die FDA, die Food and Drug Administration
und diese Behörde, die erteilt sonst einfach nur eine Zulassung zum klinischen Betrieb, der heißt (?)
Jetzt bei der Zulassung dieses Quantenzählers haben die selber eine Pressemitteilung gemacht, was ganz ungewöhnlich ist
und haben in diese Pressemitteilung reingeschrieben, dass ihrer Meinung nach das quantenzählende CT
die einzige wirklich relevante Neuerung in der Computertomographie seit zehn Jahren ist.
Das von einer US-Behörde unterstreicht, glaube ich, schon das Potenzial, das in dieser Methode steckt und das auch andere sehen.
Die Zulassung ist ja schon erfolgt.
Die Zulassung ist erfolgt ja.
Auch in Europa.
Auch in Europa ja.
Vielleicht noch mal kurz zu den Anwendungen.
Wir hatten ja jetzt gerade in dieser Corona-Zeit wieder dieses spezifische Problem, komplett neue Krankheit
und man wusste eben nicht, wie es sich auswirkt und gerade bei schwerstbetroffenen Covid-Patienten
war es ja oft so, dass dann eben, ich deute es mal als im Wesentlichen Computertomographie-Untersuchung des Körpers,
der Lunge da vorgenommen oder in viel schwarz oder viel weiß in dem Fall zu sehen war.
Wie könnte sich die Technik an der Stelle auswirken?
Ist das so seine Anwendung, wo das einen Unterschied machen könnte?
Ja, wir glauben schon, dass es auch hier einen Unterschied machen könnte.
Und zum besseren Verständnis dieser Krankheit beitragen kann.
Ein Kooperationspartner von uns zum Beispiel untersucht mit diesem Gerät jetzt eine Kohorte von Postcovid-Patienten.
Das sind Patienten, die haben die Covid-Infektion eigentlich überstanden,
haben aber Monate nach der Infektion immer noch Probleme.
Und bei denen erkennt man auch auf CT-Scans der Lunge durchaus noch Veränderungen der Lungenstruktur.
Während ein konventionelles CT nur diese Veränderung zeigen könnte, können wir jetzt mit den neuen CT auch sagen,
wie ist denn an dieser Stelle die Durchblutung der Lunge und damit der Gasaustausch beeinträchtigt?
Also wir können nicht nur sagen, schau mal, da ist irgendwas, das ist heller als es eigentlich sein sollte,
sondern wir können auch sagen, nein hier ist auch der Gasaustausch der Lunge gestört oder hier ist er nicht gestört.
Und diese Zusatzinformation kann schon helfen, solche Krankheiten besser zu verstehen.
Wie gelangt man zu dieser Einschätzung, dass der Gasaustausch gestört ist?
Also was sieht man dann, was das aussagt?
Man kann die Durchblutung des Lungenparenchyms(?) abbilden.
Durch diese Energieauflösung, also sprich durch diese spektrale Charakterisierung, die der Detektor bietet,
kann man erkennen, wo im Lungenparenchym Iod aufgenommen wurde, also das iodhaltige Kontrastmittel
und das ist ein Maß dafür, wie gut das Lungengewebe an dieser Stelle durchblutet ist.
Und da wo das Lungengewebe nicht durchblutet ist, findet auch kein Gasaustausch statt.
Okay. Ja, das ist alles sehr verheißungsvoll und weist in die Zukunft,
insofern eine angemessene Nominierung für einen Zukunftspreis aus meiner Perspektive.
Haben wir noch irgendwas wichtiges vergessen Herr Flohr?
Nein, aus meiner Sicht eigentlich nicht.
Wie lange werden wir denn jetzt noch warten müssen, bis diese Technologie Verbreitung findet?
Geht es jetzt schon los?
Es wird jetzt losgehen ja.
Diese Technologie ist jetzt ja schon bei etwa 20 Institutionen installiert in Europa und in den USA.
Und sie wird im nächsten Jahr dann generell verfügbar sein.
Also im nächsten Jahr kann sich das dann jeder kaufen.
Super.
Dann sage ich, vielen Dank für die Ausführungen.
Bitte schön.
Und ich sage auch, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist.
Bald geht es wieder weiter und bis dahin sage ich, tschüss und bis bald.